we all know that big corporations and
the rich don't pay much taxes for
example in 2015
Warren Buffett paid 1.8 million dollars
in federal income tax out of eleven
point six million dollars in income for
a rate of just under 16 percent and just
last year amazon paid no taxes at all
but how do they pull it off legally well
here are seven ways that the rich and
corporations avoid paying taxes that you
can use as well but before we start if
you're going to try to use these keep in
mind that these aren't just RAM
deductions that you never knew to use in
other words it's going to take a lot of
work from you to make these work for you
and of course make sure to check with
the local certified accountant to ensure
that you won't be here with any tax
evasion penalties but with that being
said the first method companies use is
tax havens it's a very simple concept if
tax are really high in one location
simply register your location as being
somewhere else instead there are a lot
of legal nuances to be careful of but
all companies and people with large sums
of money take advantage of this tactic
one of the most famous companies to take
advantage of this is Apple as they have
the most amount of all-cash to move
around in fact they have two hundred and
fifty two point three billion dollars in
profits offshore on which they haven't
paid a dime in US taxes between 2008 and
Apple earned 305 billion dollars before
taxes and paid a foreign tax of only at
five point eight percent during this
time Apple uses tax havens in Ireland
but you can find such places around the
world from Singapore to the Netherlands
to the Cayman Islands one of the most
prolific years of this tax loophole is
the Cayman Islands which is home to more
than 85,000 companies making one of the
few territories with more budget
organizations than people our recent
study found that approximately 21
trillion dollars is currently being
hidden in offshore tax havens so clearly
tax havens are a very popular method
next we have an ingenious way to avoid
paying capital gains taxes in most
capitalist countries you only have to
pay tax from profit is realized in other
words when you sell an asset for a
profit you don't need to have hundreds
of thousands of dollars invest in stocks
just a couple of thousand will do when
you already sell off these docks
go to an investment bank and
our money with the shares as collateral
which sets their price at a fixed rate
usually at this point most rich
investors would use the mine to invest
in something else to make more money and
then payoffs along with those profits
this way they didn't have to pay taxes
in order to reinvest their capital gains
but for you you can simply hand over
your shares to investment bank and take
the money
since this technically counts as a loan
you won't have to pay capital gains
taxes so let's say you take advantage of
these loopholes for the rest of your
life and you have a lot of my pass over
to your children usually you would have
to be inheritance or estate tax but
here's a great way to avoid this use
trust funds even if you don't have
boatloads of cash but do have a
significant chunk like a buff $50,000
this method can be worth it for you the
thing is that estate tax only focused on
actual property and capital owned by an
individual and there are a number of
exceptions to the assets that it can
target one of which being trust funds to
get the most out of a trust fund you
want to set up a grantor retained and
newly trust which invest the money for
you the best part is that any income
earned above the interest is completely
free of not only estate taxes but also
income taxes as well one of the best
examples of this tactic is that from
family Donald Trump's father Fred Crump
tardis venture very early as by the time
Donald Trump was just three years old he
was already earning $200,000 a year in
today's dollars from his father's Empire
by the time he graduated college he was
receiving the equivalent of 1 million
dollars per year and by the time he was
in his 40s and 50s he was receiving more
than 5 million dollars annually
furthermore it wasn't just Donald Trump
but his four siblings as well Fred Trump
had clearly thought this through very
well but in practice it is actually not
that hard to do and you can easily be on
your way transferring hundreds of
thousands or even millions of dollars to
your children next up what if you're
making a lot of money in cash form maybe
you're a doctor or a high-level manager
well the people say very top like CEOs
get most of the payments in terms of
stock so they can simply hold on to it
and not pay capital gains taxes until
they sell it and even when they sell it
they can simply use an investment fund
trick for example sundar Pichai wants a
Speight employees in the world made four
hundred and seventy million dollars last
year but after that only six hundred and
fifty thousand dollars was in cash or
only 0.14% but what about you
how can you take advantage of tax
loopholes if you're a fully paid in cash
well just take a look at someone who
makes a lot of money in cash which is
actress and politicians successful
actors and politicians will simply
incorporate themselves this will run you
a couple of hundred dollars but can be
very beneficial if you know how to take
advantage of it there are many
advantages to being a company while only
a few to being an earner in the top tax
bracket by channeling your wages into a
nominal corporation we're able to pay
yourself a small interest-free wage
claim expenses and then reduce income
tax if you're really wise you can devise
even more cunning ways to avoid taxes
within this for example Mitt Romney
claims a management fees of his
corporations to be capital gains rather
than income which reduces an actual rate
of tax significantly so you can
incorporate yourself to save on taxes
but while you're at it why don't you
just take your salary in terms of
dividends rather than wages now you have
to be very careful with this because you
don't want to become a victim of double
taxation
since corporations count as a separate
legal entity each corporation must file
a separate income tax return
shareholders that receive dividends from
the corporation's earnings must also pay
income tax on these gains while it seems
like you will be double taxed if you
cleverly take advantage of tax
write-offs for corporations you can
actually end up paying less think about
it like this instead of paying thirty
five percent tax upfront for a two
hundred thousand dollar salary you pay
fifteen percent as a corporation and
then fifteen percent as an individual
wait a minute how do you even get such
low percentages in the first place well
first of all you can take advantage of
corporate tax write-offs and loopholes
that aren't available as an individual
like writing off portion of your
dividends you pay yourself which makes
your corporate taxes very small then
only give yourself the amount of money
you need to live comfortably for example
if you made $200,000 you wouldn't spend
all of it in fact you probably wouldn't
even spend most of it let's say you're a
conservative person who only needs sixty
five thousand dollars a year then only
give herself a salary of about eighty
thousand dollars which is moderately
split between wages and dividends maybe
$50,000
and $30,000 and dividends this way
you're in $80,000 tax bracket instead of
a $200,000 tax bracket mean that you
won't have to pay 22 percent income tax
on this money and with deductions and
write-offs you can definitely get that
to 15 percent or even lower but despite
paying less taxes we'd be living the
life of $200,000 as it definitely would
not be spending $60,000 per year if you
were actually only making $80,000 a year
or at least I hope you wouldn't because
then you wouldn't have any savings I
know that that was a lot of hassle but
in the end we were able to pay 30% tax
instead of 35 percent it would both
probably actually be a bit lower but the
difference would remain about five
percent while five percent sounds small
that's actually a solid $10,000 and that
number just keeps increasing the more
money you make
moving on do you have a second house
that you rent out if so you can create
some tax-free capital gains by borrowing
against the value of that property this
is often very popular with giant real
estate investment firms but you don't
actually need that much money to benefit
from this as well let's say you bought a
$50,000 house in cash and developing
neighborhood and after a couple of years
the value of the house increases to
$75,000 you can go to a bank and get a
cash refund ance for 80% of the value of
the property giving you back $60,000 now
use your rental income to pay the
mortgage and take the $60,000 and put it
into another house and repeat this
process over and over again if you
started cycling in late 20s by a time
and hit your 60s you will have made
hundreds of thousands of dollars by
leveraging your equity all while
avoiding long term capital gains taxes
this is very similar to deburr strategy
which stands for by rehab rent refinance
and repeat and huge companies have taken
advantage of this for decades leading to
billions of dollars in gains without
taxes finally yeah municipal bonds
governments at every level
issue municipal bonds to finance
large-scale project like schools and
highways and of course any investment or
government is seen as a no risk
investment but not only will you get
your money back for sure
earning some unified bonds are exempt
from federal income taxes so let's say
you're an average person who is in the
twenty eight percent tax bracket if you
purchase a municipal bond that pays five
percent interest that's equivalent of
getting a seven point five percent
return on invest
because you don't have to pay income tax
on that 5% municipal bonds are available
to ordinary taxpayers as well as the
ultra-rich and not only do they provide
tax savings but are a great way to
invest locally and support your
community so there's seven ways the rich
avoid taxes that you can use to but
here's the thing
none of those tactics are really worth
their time as it comes out to such small
savings it's not worth it for rich
people either to do it themselves that's
why they get accountants to do it for
them considering that if you're an
average person just make smart spending
choices and don't spend most of your
income and then take the rest of money
you make and put into a Roth IRA or 401k
depending on which one is better for you
or whatever retirement vehicle is most
popular in your country as long as you
consider lis spend your money throughout
your early career you should be able to
max out your contributions to these
accounts and by the time you reach
mid-career and late career this should
be a piece of cake eventually when you
retire you'll have at least a million
dollars and save a lot in taxes as well
if you're feeling especially ambitious
feel free to go into other investment
paths and use all of the tax benefits
that you can think of as that will no
doubt produce greater returns but for
most people this will be more than
enough but that's what I think what do
you guys think are you guys mad that
companies avoid taxes by using these
loopholes make sure comment that down
below also we just like this video that
mentioned drop a like and consider
subscribing right see more videos just
like this one but until then I'm Ari
I'll see you guys on the next one
you